vous venez de le voir avec ce
documentaire signé par David carbrown
les géants américains du numérique
jettent désormais leur dévolu sur le
secteur de la santé ils aspirent à
pouvoir traiter demain tous nos mots
prédire notre avenir biologique et
par-dessus tout conquérir un marché qui
s’annonce mirobolant ou s'arrêtera cette
offensive au moment où les systèmes de
santé nationaux et public donne
d'important signe de fragilité nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc avec vous tout d'abord Tariq crimes
bienvenue à vous vous êtes entrepreneur
dans le domaine numérique fondateur de
net vibe jolie cloud de police également
vous êtes aussi initiateur du mouvement
sloweb qui vise à nous désintoxiquer on
va dire les choses comme ça de l'emprise
des gafams justement et aussi ancien
vice-président du Conseil National du
Numérique philippe Juvin est également
avec nous bienvenue à vous merci vous
êtes députés les républicains des
Hauts-de-Seine ancien député européen et
professeur de médecine chef de service
des urgences de l'hôpital Georges
Pompidou à Paris bien entendu puis enfin
Coralie la MQ est également parmi nous
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste pour le
magazine Science et Avenir et auteur de
ma santé mes données alors là on est en
plein dans le sujet publié chez premier
parallèle tous les opérateurs ces fameux
gafams sont très très loin de leur coeur
de métier lorsqu'on parle du secteur
médical
qu'est-ce qui motive
l'investissement massif auquel on
assiste aujourd'hui du côté des gafams
dans ce domaine des santé là pas du gain
tout simplement
non je crois pas je pense que les gafams
se sont construits il faut bien
comprendre à partir de plusieurs
innovations par exemple Google a démarré
comme un moteur de recherche ensuite
c'est devenu le cœur de notre vie
numérique avec les emails avec tous les
outils que l'on a et donc
progressivement par strat ils ont occupé
de nouveaux terrains alors à chaque fois
qu'un terrain commençait à baisser par
exemple aujourd'hui tout le monde sur la
planète a un smartphone donc il faut
imaginer les prochains relais de
croissance et beaucoup de gens pensent
que la médecine ou en tout cas une
partie de la médecine l'accès à aux
soins à la prévention pourrait être l'un
des prochains relais de croissance
relais de croissance donc on part bien
de de business
d'économie avec un marché quand même
considérable le marché de la santé aux
États-Unis un 3700 milliards de dollars
c'est 18% du du PIB américain puis alors
là on parle d'un marché global qui
s'établissait environ à 350 milliards de
dollars en 2019 mais mais qui pourra
atteindre
600 milliards de dollars en 2024 c'est
demain tout de même les gains à espérer
pour les Gafa dans cette affaire sont
considérables oui alors il faut bien
comprendre une chose c'est que déjà aux
États-Unis la façon dont on voit la
médecine est totalement différente de la
manière dont on la voit notamment en
France où on est en France plutôt sur
quels sont les bénéfices de la
technologie pour la collectivité quand
on est souvent sur la question de la
médecine personnelle personnalisée voire
ultra personnelle et c'est vrai qu'une
partie des gafams se dise aujourd'hui
avec l'ensemble des outils des
informations que l'on a sur vous par
exemple simplement la taille de vos
vêtements qui permettent de savoir si
vous êtes obèse ou si vous avez un poids
correct ce que vous achetez les produits
puisque vous avez acheté également
quasiment tout en ligne maintenant on
est capable de voir parmi l'ensemble des
Américains les quelques dizaines
peut-être la centaine de millions de
ceux qui sont en forme qui sont
[Musique]
une médecine où il est moins question du
nombre de lithopitaux que de diagnostic
individuel et précoce une médecine dont
l'objectif n'est plus d'attendre que les
gens tombent malades pour les soigner et
où il s'agit avant tout de prévenir
plutôt que de guérir la promesse c'est
ça
guérir alors c'est une promesse qui fait
rêver évidemment les malades et qui fait
rêver tous les pouvoirs publics qui
doivent diriger des systèmes de santé
parce que évidemment c'est c'est la
promesse aussi d'économie importante du
côté des différents pouvoirs publics
alors c'est une des promesses c'est pas
la seule probablement mieux guérir mieux
diagnostiquer précocement etc mais ça
fait des années que tous les pays à
économie de type occidentale disent il
faut faire de la prévention et on voit
qu'on a de la difficulté à faire de la
prévention et là
on arrive peut-être au moment où la
prévention va être peut-être plus facile
plus efficace plus opérationnelle grâce
aux données donc moi je crois
effectivement qu'il y a un champ immense
qui s'ouvre brutalement parce que la
prévention n'en parle depuis des années
mais on en fait pas beaucoup où on en
fait à l'ancienne manière et du carnet à
souche on marque et là
l'arrivée brutale de donner immense va
permettre de prévoir votre évolution
peut-être votre évolution de votre état
de santé à vous grâce à l'analyse de
millions d'autres cas qui vous
ressemblent et c'est vrai que c'est une
promesse formidable
depuis des années et Dieu sait si vous
avez raison autrement dit on n'avait pas
encore les outils
je crois que c'est ça la grande
nouveauté enfin c'est une une des
promesses moi je préfère évidemment
prévenir l'arrivée d'un cancer plutôt
que traiter un cancer qu'on traite
encore encore assez mal juste pour un
point sur le ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure vous avez dit il y a pourquoi il
s'intéresse les gars femme
s'intéresse-t-il à la santé est-ce que
c'est une question de marché oui mais en
réalité la question vous pourriez la
poser au laboratoire pharmaceutique
pourquoi finalement le seul lance-t-il
dans la lutte contre le cancer au
fabricant des scanners etc donc en soi
ce n'est pas une difficulté ça c'est une
observation c'est vrai qu'un marché de
la santé parce que il y a un besoin mais
il invente pas un marché à partir de
rien il y a un besoin de santé qui n'est
pas résolu si ces nouvelles techniques
permettent de le résoudre moi je suis le
plus heureux des hommes comme médecin et
peut-être comme passion le nerf de la
guerre
bien sûr le stockage des des données les
fameux cloud mais ça c'est le nerf de la
guerre que ce livre ces fameux gafam et
puis la collecte la récolte des données
qui sera ensuite traitée par de
l'intelligence artificielle on en
parlera peut-être tout à l'heure c'est
au cœur de votre livre
est-ce qu'on peut un temps soit peu
espérer nous européen par exemple nous
Français protéger nos données
personnelles après avoir vu ce
documentaire et vu offensif que vont
nous livrer ces grands opérateurs du
numérique américain il faut savoir que
en Europe on est infiniment mieux
protégé quand même qu'aux États-Unis de
par tout simplement le rgpd le règlement
général sur la protection des données la
CNIL également en France qui interdit la
collecte de nos données de santé et leur
traitement sans accord de du patient la
loi evint aussi qui fait qu'on ne peut
pas moduler des tarifs par exemple par
rapport aux données de santé d'un client
donc tout ça fait qu'on est quand même
dans un autre paradigme ici qu'aux
États-Unis et pourtant dans votre livre
vous dites attention le transfert des
données personnelles y compris en France
ça a déjà commencé non ça n'a pas
commencé mais c'est sûr que il faut pas
si l'Europe va rester telle qu'elle est
sur ces sujets là il faut pas baisser la
garde puisque les grands acteurs
aujourd'hui sont américains et dépendent
de la législation américaine je pense à
Microsoft à qui on avait confié
en France donc c'est cette immense
plateforme de données de santé qui
récolte tous nos passages à l'hôpital à
la pharmacie de façon anonisée mais tout
de même
idem pour Amazon par exemple à qui a été
confiée le Cloud de Doctissimo de
doctolib pardon donc c'est sûr que ce
sont ces acteurs là qui sont choisis
chez nous pas de par leur force et de
par leur expertise mais il faut rester
vigilant sur le point du point de vue
législatif oui alors en France on veut
créer le Elf datadum qui vit justement
un collecter un certain nombre de
données qui existent alors à la fois
dans l'administration de la santé dans
certains hôpitaux tout ça est pas très
harmonieux pour l'instant assez dispersé
si je si j'ai bien compris en préparant
ce dossier mais alors il y a ce projet
qui est sur la table mais celui qui va
héberger les données de ce projet les
données potentielles de ce projet ça
sera Microsoft ça sera un Américain on
n'arrive pas à nous à monter un tel
projet très ambitieux qui
que la France va porter qu'elle pourrait
même porter à l'échelle européenne ce
projet sans avoir un hébergeur
américain qui s'appelle en l'occurrence
Microsoft
moi personnellement je pense alors
j'aurais peut-être dû démarrer par ça
tout à l'heure bien indiqué qu'il y a
dans le domaine de la santé numérique
deux types de d'acteurs vous avez les
laboratoires les acteurs de ce qu'on
appelle les biotech par exemple moderna
qu'on a découvert avec le covid donc ils
sont des gens qui veulent améliorer la
médecine et dont d'ailleurs le F data va
permettre d'une certaine manière de le
faire et les acteurs comme les gafam
donc les acteurs du numérique qui
veulent eux également développer des
activités de type médical mais qui ne
sont pas les mêmes alors ce qui est
intéressant avec avec je pense que c'est
aussi le je pense le coeur du débat
c'est quelle est la vision que l'on a de
la médecine parce qu'on est vraiment sur
un modèle qui est totalement différent
aux États-Unis ou votre sécurité sociale
est associée à votre à votre travail
vous n'avez plus de travail plus de
sécurité sociale énormément de gens ne
sont pas assurés ont des services
vraiment très très peu optimales on l'a
vu pendant le covid on a vu aussi à quel
point la médecine en France était à la
fois résiliente et fonctionnait bien et
donc cette idée je crois de table c'est
à la fois une forme de rêve parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de ces acteurs qui ont lu
la science-fiction des années 50 des
années 60 et qui imaginent effectivement
un monde parfait ou l'intelligence
artificielle résoudrait tous les
problèmes à mon avis le
véritable véritable question qu'on doit
se poser par rapport à ça c'est quels
sont les ressources dont on dispose en
Europe et je pense que contrairement à
ce que l'on dit il y a énormément
d'acteurs de très bonne qualité les
leaders de l'intelligence artificielle
par exemple ce sont à l'INRIA vous avez
des autres des acteurs de stockage un
peu partout et on aurait dû concevoir un
système qui s'appuie sur nos ressources
nos talents locaux malheureusement comme
il y avait des contraintes de temps
d'après ce que j'ai compris on a été au
plus rapide et Microsoft a été présenté
comme l'acteur le problème c'est que
effectivement les données qui sont
hébergées sur des services de type
Microsoft Google Amazon sont soumis à ce
qu'on appelle le cloudac donc vous savez
des ces règles extra et territoriales
qui permettent aux États-Unis au service
de renseignement et voir aussi au
Département de la Justice d'avoir accès
à ces données donc ça pose un véritable
problème parce qu'une fois qu'on a mis
ses données qui a accès comment pour
quoi et on est pas certain de garantir
que seuls les acteurs européens ou
duMans concernés iront accès on l'a
entendu dans ce film d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de d'intervenants qui
disent que la solution passera par un
échange et une collecte européenne
justement pour faire face à cette
offensive dont on parle aujourd'hui vous
y croyez est-ce que ça fait bonne forme
à quelles conditions d'abord il y a
plusieurs conditions il faut des outils
juridiques nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas par exemple de marché
unique numérique on tend à le construire
il n'y a pas de pour parler français il
y a pas de règle juridique qui font que
les données ou la vente de celle-ci ou
la disposition de celle-ci vont être
pareillement traitées dans tous les pays
de marché unique des biens tangibles
mais il n'y a pas encore l'équivalent
numérique ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point il faudrait pas au motif
que on veut super se protéger etc et
encore une fois je suis pour la
régulation qu'on revive l'erreur que
nous avons fait à 15 ans quand on s'est
dit en France on va faire un truc
formidable qui est le DMP le dossier
médical personnalisé ça fait 15 ans
qu'on l'attend ça consisterait à quoi
que vous ayez un dossier médical dans le
Cloud qui ferait que quand vous allez
voir votre médecin traitant votre kiné
votre pharmacien ou moi à l'hôpital et
bien en plus avoir les mêmes
informations ça fait 15 ans qu'on
l'attend et ça fait 15 ans qu'on dit
mais non on va y arriver et on y est
toujours pas et donc qui paye la facture
c'est le patient qui est probablement
pas suffisamment bien traité donc
attention aussi nous avons cette
capacité en Europe et parfois aussi en
France a tellement réfléchir sur les
conséquences malheureuses d'une
découverte qu'on ne profite pas de la
découverte je pense qu'il faut être très
vigilant enfin dernier soin
si on n'est pas actif là-dessus vous
savez ce qui va se passer c'est que les
passions eux-mêmes vont confier leurs
données à ces gars femme moi je il y a
plein de sites ou quand vous avez une
maladie pas de diabète vous inscrivez
sur le site vous donnez vos informations
et aux motifs que vous avez des
informations nouvelles etc
en fait vous confiez librement sans
aucune régulation vos données donc
attention parce que l'absence de
décision peut nous conduire à Pierre
pour rajouter que les gafam ont des
ambitions dans le domaine de la santé
mais c'est quand même vraiment pas leur
coeur de métier on travaille avec eux
pour leur puissance algorithmique mais
tous les projets qu'il mènent sont
adossés à la recherche en Europe et
ailleurs aux hôpitaux aux grands
instituts et sans ces données là et sans
cette intelligence là ce savoir-faire il
ne serait quand même rien dans le
domaine de la santé même si leur
puissance de brassage des données est
très fortes c'est pour ça qu'on ait
choisi c'est quand même pas leur coeur
de métier et avec ce projet elle data
dub projet français ce qu'on aurait la
certitude d'une bonne protection des
données personnelles médicales et de
santé des Français en l'occurrence voir
des Européens si ce projet va prendre
une dimension européenne alors sur le
réalisateur il y a en effet il y a deux
types de prospection différents d'une
part les données sont chiffrées donc ça
veut dire que de l'extérieur on ne peut
pas y avoir accès sans avoir une clé de
chiffrement que on a souvent de
l'intérieur c'est comme si c'était un
cryptés en gros et par ailleurs elles
sont anonymisées donc c'est pas écrit
Coralie l'aime que un rhume etc donc il
y a quand même ces deux protections là
et il faut rappeler que le réalisateur
c'est pas juste une plateforme pour
s'amuser à tout mettre ensemble sur une
plateforme commune elle est destinée à
des grands projets de recherche pour
faire avancer nos connaissances dans les
traitements sur les grandes maladies le
cancer etc c'est vraiment pour faire
avancer la connaissance en médecine et
peut-être vous peut-être moi demain
pouvoir bénéficier de cette recherche
donc vraiment faire progresser la
science c'est ça le problème de français
français nous connaîtrait pas le sort
qui a failli connaître le NHS
britannique qui est
cité et dont on parle beaucoup dans ce
documentaire
a donné ses données de santé pour une
livre sterline symbolique au moment du
covid en effet eux ils ont franchi le
pas et c'est non on n'est pas du tout là
en France vous avez raison il faut être
évidemment éviter ça et en même temps il
faut que nous nous doutions d'outils qui
sont des outils opérationnels et parce
que encore une fois sans outil
opérationnel les gens eux-mêmes vont se
prendre en charge avec des outils qui ne
fonctionneront pas je vous donne un
exemple quand vous arrivez dans un
service d'urgence aujourd'hui vous avez
une fracture si vous n'avez pas
d'orthopédiste sur place que fait le
médecin il prend une photo avec son
iPhone de votre de votre radio il prend
WhatsApp donc tout ça sans aucune
garantie et il envoie à son copain
orthopédiste qui connaît en disant
qu'est-ce que tu penses de cette
fracture et et voyez si les systèmes ne
sont pas fluides
facile à utiliser et bien ils ne seront
pas utilisés et c'est vrai que les
gafams ont cet avantage d'avoir créé des
environnements très très friand de lit
très très agréable à très très très
utilisable et ça attention c'est un
fondamental on entendait là d'ailleurs à
un de vos confrères qui te qui a été
nommé monsieur numérique au ministère de
la Santé qui lui croyait pas aux géants
il a commencé dans des hôpitaux CHU je
crois que c'est à Montpellier
à mettre un système de collecte de
données etc
est-ce que c'est la bonne démarche de ne
pas avoir un géant
aujourd'hui face à d'autres géants
est-ce que c'est quand même pas la
finalité de des recherches qui sont en
cours du côté français pour cette grande
banque de données
j'ai fait attention au marketing qui est
aussi parce qu'il y a toujours autour
des de cette idée cette petite musique
en fait en Europe on sait pas faire et
qu'aux États-Unis on serait mieux faire
alors qu'en fait souvent les ingénieurs
qui développent les plateformes aux
États-Unis sont français allemand
anglais je crois qu'il y a déjà
énormément d'acteurs locaux je pense que
c'est aussi un des débats parce qu'on en
a pas parlé mais il y a également un
autre sujet qui apparaît avec notamment
la guerre en Ukraine qui est la question
géopolitique que se passe-t-il si les
câbles sous-marins si la question de la
résilience nous donnait c'est toute nos
données sont aux États-Unis ou si demain
par exemple on a parlé de doctolib
entreprise privée qui a assuré une
mission de service public qui demande
point de vue était une mission
régalienne la vaccination ça n'aurait
pas dû être fait il y a plein d'autres
choses qui n'auraient pas dû être faites
à cette période mais si demain une
société comme Amazon par exemple pour ne
pas le citer décide d'acheter cette
société que fait-on comment fait-on
quelle est la résidence c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut on le voit aujourd'hui avec
le domaine de l'énergie la santé n'est
pas très loin aussi il faut à la fois
réfléchir des systèmes efficaces mais
aussi réfléchir à les systèmes
résilients notamment dans un
environnement et vous aviez raison parce
que il est vrai qu'en Europe tout le
monde n'a pas la même vision de la santé
mais également du numérique de bien
réfléchir à quelle est notre quels sont
nos valeurs quelles sont aussi nos
atouts quels sont les entreprises et on
a des géants aussi on a des gens comme
Dassault Systèmes qui ont acheté des
entreprise dans ce domaine et donc qui
connaissent bien tout ça comment
s'assurer que l'on construit que la
santé numérique est une opportunité pour
la France de devenir un des acteurs
majeurs parce que dans la santé on n'est
plus on est plutôt bon on a on est on
est quand même assez assez bien côté au
niveau international y compris dans les
domaines de l'intelligence artificielle
ou les chercheurs français sont très
bons donc la combinaison de l'ensemble
de ces forces permet d'imaginer que dans
les cinq dix ans à côté de la Chine à
côté des États-Unis l'Europe mais
surtout la France qui a une singularité
dans le numérique pour être un des
acteurs majeur alors l'intelligence
artificielle c'est la manière dont on va
traiter évidemment c'est donner en quoi
on peut laisser espérer les patients les
malades
grâce à ce que va nous procurer
l'intelligence artificielle déjà on
utilise par exemple on a des logiciels
qu'on utilise tous les jours de lecture
des radiographies ou des scanners c'est
à dire que on peut passer un scanner
l'image arrive sur l'écran et au lieu
que ça soit un radiologue qui regarde et
etc le radiologue regarde toujours bien
entendu mais vous avez un logiciel qui
analyse des millions de données de
millions de scanner de gens qui ont
passé le scanner pour les mêmes raisons
que vous et qui ont appris de tout ça et
qui vous disent bah attention là il y a
un symptôme un signe qui laisse penser
que vous avez tel pathologie ou c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire que vous pourriez
dans l'avenir développer tel pathologie
ou est plus simplement par exemple moi
dans mon service on a un logiciel qui
fait diagnostic des fractures quand vous
avez les radiographies des eaux vous
avez tous vu là il vous l'entoure ça
c'est formidable parce que ça nous fait
gagner du temps et de la sécurité donc
ça c'est formidable et pour revenir ce
que vous disiez il faut à la fois en
fait c'est un équilibre subtil entre une
protection d'une régulation une
proximité une protection de données une
souveraineté parce que ce que vous
décrivez c'est de la souveraineté et et
moi je crois peut-être pour répondre
peut-être un peu différemment qui il y a
un avantage à avoir un gigantisme ce que
le gigantisme vous permet d'avoir
beaucoup beaucoup de données et donc
d'avoir des machines qui s'appuient sur
une expérience beaucoup plus importante
que sur un petit nombre donc et puis
alors vous disiez c'est vrai que les
champions français c'est vrai on a des
champions français mais quand je discute
avec des gens qui travaillent là-dessus
des startups comme disent-ils ils me
disent notre vraie sujet en France c'est
que nous n'avons pas facilement accès au
marché et comme nous n'avons pas accès
au marché il y a un moment pour
développer ma boîte qu'est-ce que je
fais je suis obligé de la vendre et
souvent je la vends acquis à ceux qui
ont de l'argent et qui ont de l'argent
c'est les gafam donc on a un problème
quand même de d'accès au marché sur
l'apport potentiel de l'intelligence
artificielle sur la base des données qui
aurait pu être récoltées
plus on peut passer c'est comme un
peigne fin qu'on passe comme ça à
travers un amas immense de données et on
arrive à repérer des symptômes on arrive
à repérer je sais pas des patterns
comprendre pourquoi tel traitement va
marcher chez vous pas chez moi par
exemple donc c'est une richesse infinie
mais il faut savoir les protéger ses
données pour pouvoir en tirer le
meilleur en toute sécurité pour pour
tout le monde alors aujourd'hui quels
sont les maladies qui sont
particulièrement suivies et où on peut
espérer des vrais progrès grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle on a tous
les jours dans le domaine du cancer par
exemple
toutes ces grandes maladies qui touchent
nous notre entourage mais aussi dans les
maladies rares par exemple pour lesquels
on a très très peu de données donc on
agrège je sais pas 200 personnes à
travers le monde qui ont une maladie
rare on arrive du coup à comprendre
pourquoi
comment les les traités etc donc à la
fois sur des voilà des grosses
pathologies mais aussi plus isolément
comme ça sur des maladies dont on ne
sait pas grand chose en fait et c'est
grâce à lia que qu'on arrive à avancer
il y a des choses
[Musique]
en médecine c'est simple c'est comme
dans tout dans la vie on fait bien ce
qu'on fait souvent d'accord et quand
vous avez des pathologies qui ont sans
patience sur toute la France et que vous
êtes le spécialiste de cette maladie par
définition vous n'envoyez pas beaucoup
puisqu'ils sont ça en France et bien
peut-être que certainement avec ce type
d'outils le médecin qui dans toute sa
vie aura du 100 personnes va pouvoir
bénéficier de donner qui viennent du
monde entier et il aura non pas des
connaissances à partir de 100 personnes
mais de milliers sur le monde entier et
puis sur les anciens par exemple la mayo
clinique vous avez vu dans votre topo
c'était formidable ils vont reprendre
toutes les données de la maiochnique
depuis que la mayo existe et et aux
États-Unis qu'on a vu dans ce
documentaire c'est le plus grand bel
hôpital dit-on du monde absolument et
bien ils vont reprendre des données
médicales qui sont pas de patients qui
existent aujourd'hui mais qui existait
il y a 10 20 30 ans et donc c'est ça
aussi c'est
le nuage doit être très très gros le
Cloud doit être très très gros pour être
très productif
autre question c'est vrai que la
recherche médicale aujourd'hui c'est le
domaine des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
est-ce que les gafams vont supplanter
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques pour ce
qui concerne la recherche médicale
demain
personnellement je le crois pas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui chacun d'entre eux entre
les laboratoires donc ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure et c'est très juste c'est
que quand on est médecin aujourd'hui en
fait ce qu'on découvre c'est qu'on va
avoir à sa disposition des outils
extraordinaires beaucoup plus rapide
beaucoup plus simple et puis je crois
aussi vous l'avez dit mais c'est le
domaine de la science et on l'a vu avec
le covid aussi c'est la la collaboration
internationale qui permet d'aller
beaucoup plus vite c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles on a été aussi rapide
pour les vaccins c'est que quasiment
tous les gens ne travaillaient que des
monos sujets donc on a eu une quand même
un très bel exemple
donc d'un côté moi je crois que les gars
femme s'intéressent à vous en tant
qu'individu donc il faut bien séparer je
crois les ce qu'on appelle les données
personnelles donc qui vous êtes le
nombre de pas que vous faites par jour
votre taille ce que vous mangez des
données médicales et pour moi les
données médicales c'est du domaine du
médecin et dans un environnement de gens
qui ont je dirais le serment la
démocrate et de l'autre côté vous avez
les données personnelles qui peuvent
permettre d'une certaine manière de
comprendre certaines choses que vous
allez développer mais on n'est pas du
tout dans les mêmes dans les mêmes
domaines je crois que les laboratoires
de recherche eux travaillent sur les
choses qui vont être vraiment en pointe
les deux nouvelles maladies de nouvelles
façons de pardon de mais aussi de
nouvelles maladies mais de nouvelles
façons de guérir certaines maladies
quand les gafams vont apporter ça c'est
un service supplémentaire un peu comme
une assurance on va vous aider à bien
vous organiser à prévenir oui alors
aujourd'hui
prenons je suis un laboratoire
pharmaceutique je mets au point un
nouvel molécule pour traiter
l'hypertension artérielle je vais faire
un essai clinique je vais prendre un
groupe de passions de plus de 65 ans à
qui je veux donner le médicament et un
groupe de patients de plus de 65 ans qui
je vais pas le donner puis je vais
comparer les résultats si ça marche je
verrai que la tension artérielle baisse
dans le groupe qui reçoit mon super
nouveau médicament peut-être que si
aujourd'hui je vais le donner le
médicament et puis je vais pas voir de
différents peut-être justement parce que
les groupes ne sont pas bien choisis et
là peut-être que les données vont nous
aider à mieux faire des essais cliniques
peut-être que au fond le bon groupe
c'est pas les hommes de plus de 65 ans
mais c'est les hommes de plus de 65 ans
avec des antécédents familiaux comme si
ils ont des antécédents personnels comme
ça et faire des sous-groupes et
peut-être la définition de sous-groupe
de patients avec des médicaments qui
vont être plus efficaces sur des
sous-groupes de patients
d'identification de ces sous-groupes de
patients qui vont permettre de cibler
l'efficacité des médicaments sera-t-elle
facilité par par tous ces outils donc la
recherche va évidemment bénéficier de
cela
je pense mais toutes les données de
santé ne se valent pas il y a la donnée
de santé telle qu'on l'a on la définit
dans le cadre législatif donc tout ce
qui donne une information sur la santé
je sais pas une radio de fracture ma
correction de lunettes un passage à la
pharmacie et après il y a toutes ces
données annexes le fait que je fasse je
sais pas moi 7000 pas par jour ça te dit
rien de ma santé
un poids tout seul ça ne dit rien de ma
santé le nombre de calories que je mange
par jour ça ne dit rien de ma santé
c'est quand elles sont croisées avec nos
véritables données de santé que ça peut
donner une information si on sait que je
fais pas beaucoup de pas par jour 2000
pas
ça nous dit rien si on sait que par
ailleurs je ne glycémie un petit peu
élevée on peut se dire ah peut-être
qu'il y a une obésité peut-être qu'il y
a des maladies cardiovasculaires mais
seul ce que nous dit la Fitbit de Google
l'Apple watch en réalité ça nous informe
pas beaucoup et d'ailleurs les gafam
n'arrive pas à faire grand chose avec
ces informations là qu'il connaît sur
nous c'est parce qu'il travaille les
hôpitaux qui arrivent à faire
oui mais en même temps ce qui est très
important c'est les croisements non pas
entre société médical mais avec d'autres
acteurs je l'exemple je reviens sur le
covid avant quand on avait du diabète
l'hypertension des maladies comme ça bon
on l'avait du diabète l'hypertension
voilà c'est comme ça on se traite dans
le monde covid et parce que vide ça
devient ce qu'on appelait une
comorbidité ça a été le nouveau terme
qu'on a appris pendant ces deux
dernières années et qui dit commode
méditer dit peut-être que le prêt
immobilier qu'un ensemble d'éléments qui
est jusqu'à maintenant était on va dire
n'était pas affectée par ce type de de
symptômes de
changer donc ce qui est ce qui est aussi
à la fois fascinant c'est cette capacité
de mieux mieux mieux comprendre en tant
qu'individu j'ai envie de savoir si je
fais suffisamment de pas dans la journée
mais il y a cette inquiétude et c'est à
mon avis une inquiétude qui est
justifiée que mes données qui me
représentent moins ne vont pas aller un
peu partout être croisé par des acteurs
qui vont utiliser ça pour changer la
relation imagine par exemple vous voulez
citer les assurances l'utilisation pour
en faire les assurances bien sûr
pour l'instant c'est tous un peu
félicité sur ce plateau de des avancées
que tout cela va pouvoir procurer pour
les malades évidemment en priorité mais
aussi pour les gafams les principaux
opérateurs il y a tout de même des
limites à tout ça évidemment sont-elles
ses limites mais d'une certaine manière
elles existaient déjà dans le monde non
numérique quand vous faites un scanner
chez vous je vous fais un scanner on
vous découvre une maladie cancéreuse
aujourd'hui le compte-rendu du scanner
dans lequel c'est marqué que vous avez
un cancer vous avez vous n'allez pas le
donner à votre à votre assureur votre
assureur s'il en fait la demande on va
pas lui envoyer vous voyez donc il y a
déjà des limites dans le monde réel il
faut que ces limites elles soient
travaillées dans le monde numérique mais
dès qu'on a une pathologie souvent la
première chose qu'on fait c'est d'aller
sur google pour aller taper et à partir
de là d'ailleurs le documentaire il
commence comme ça tout le monde au moins
taper une fois sur Google des des
tablettes
on crée des porosités et à partir de là
c'est vrai que la réglementation en
Europe est assez claire en France elle
est plutôt claire faut quand même le
dire aux États-Unis c'est beaucoup moins
clair et surtout dans cette avec cette
idée qu'on l'a vu avec certains
employeurs parce qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'aux États-Unis l'employeur paye pour
l'Assurance Maladie est-ce qu'il n'est
pas le cas ici vous pouvez être chômeur
et avoir une assurance maladie c'est
moins le cas aux États-Unis donc ce pose
cette question de savoir qui sont les
gens en bonne santé donc qui sont
rentables d'un point de vue des
investissements et ceux qui le sont
moins et qui pourraient être moins
rentables et cette idée d'une médecine à
deux vitesses aux États-Unis en plus de
celle qui existe déjà entre ceux qui ont
et ceux qui n'ont pas une assurance
maladie
se pose vous envoyez de votre des
limites justement sans faire trop de
science-fiction c'est un peu la fin du
documentaire on ouvre des scénarios
possibles finalement avec les avancées
que ça va procurer
qu'est-ce que vous fait peur finalement
vous dans cette avancée fondamentalement
moi je dois dire que je suis assez
rassurée quand même sur l'état de notre
législation et de ce que voilà notre
protection qu'on a ici en France et a
fortiori en Europe le rgpd est quand
même bien mis en place etc la CNIL et là
aussi pour nous protéger c'est vrai que
tout ce qui concerne les gafams donc les
pleins doivent être envoyés la CNIL
irlandaise spécifiquement parce que
c'est là-bas qu'ils ont souvent leur
lieu ils sont établis la CNIL irlandaise
traite
0,07% des plaintes qu'elle reçoit donc
là il y a un vrai lien j'imagine puisque
c'est là où se situe les sièges des
gafams
donc c'est vrai que les plaintes ne sont
pas traitées c'est
99,93% des plantes qui ne sont pas
traitées donc il y a quand même un
manque ici auquel il faudrait pas lier
mais honnêtement à part ça je trouve
qu'on est quand même on est quand même
plutôt bien protégé il y a peut-être
aussi un élément qu'il faudra un jour
aborder même certainement c'est la
question morale
prenons un exemple qui est à la limite
de la santé mais vous allez comprendre
c'est la voiture autonome on en parle
voiture autonome qui est guidée par un
algorithme il y a un moment où il faudra
quelqu'un programme dans l'algorithme
que faire si un enfant passe devant la
voiture quand vous faites des études de
de que font les gens le conducteur
normal pour éviter l'enfant la plupart
du temps en 80% il va décider lui-même
d'aller dans le poteau pour ne pas tuer
l'enfant et bien l'algorithme faudra
qu'un jour on décide que quand un enfant
passe devant la voiture et bien la
voiture doit aller dans le poteau ou ou
heurter l'enfant oui c'est une question
morale et donc
c'est un sujet qui est très transversal
qui n'est pas que technique ce sera le
mot de la fin je suis désolé mais on a
passé un excellent moment et surtout
grâce à vous on en sait beaucoup plus
maintenant sur la médecine tech et c'est
offensive des des gafam sur ce marché de
la santé mondiale aujourd'hui après ce
documentaire vos réactions ce sera sur
hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter à mon avis
elles seront assez nombreuses après
l'échange que nous avons voulu ensemble
et ce film que nous venons de voir merci
à Selma Sally qui comme à l'accoutumée
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission puis
moi je vous donne rendez-vous tout
simplement pour un prochain les Badoc et
ça sera bien sûr avec son documentaire
et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]